this week's episode brought to you by
gray block pizza at 1811 Pico Boulevard
in Los Angeles on the way to the beach
you headed to the sunshine you want some
sand in your feet on the way they are
stopped in get that Italian mouthful you
know
gray block get that hitter this week's
episode brought to you by my West Coast
buds
it is a podcast it is a show with an
inside look at cannabis comedy coffee
and Saudi Arabia no I'm joking spirits
like alcohol cannabis coffee comedy and
spirits it's all of my favorite vices a
gentleman named Joe Demi oh and that
could be you know
Dimmie Oh could be anything Italian
foreign basic local sounds like a young
everything but Jodi mio owns a
dispensary in Tigard Oregon
that's that Upper East Coast bud shop
and the place is called Kola Cove and he
also acts as a cannabis consultant Joe
teaches people how to get into the wee
game as a way to keep the bills paid
while he works on being a stand-up comic
so Joe smoke buds buy a day jokes by
night
that's what Joe Demio is doing his show
my West Coast buds is a fun inside
baseball look at all of those industries
comedy and weed how to make whiskey how
to grow pot how to craft a proper dick
joke stiff like that this week's guest
comedian is Caitlin Weyerhaeuser and
they talk about comedy and why she's
offended and she's never been haunted by
a ghost the link will be below all right
now let's get involved in each other's
lives
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it Brad Levine right there and
that's better off barefoot and that is a
sending by Brad Levine and we're
thankful for that
hitter right there it is it is May 14th
and it's the year 2018 and that is
that's what's going on we're out here in
the Millennium we're out here in the
universe
you know we had Eddie Bravo in on on the
on as a guest this past week and that
man he's keyed up
he's keyed up on life you know every
time you talked to him it seemed like
he's on about a about an Eightball of
just existence you know you ask him
anything and you know he just goes off
he's like a golden retriever with a
hearing problem no I'm saying he's off
he's gone you know I'm saying he's Kay
he's out there chasing invisible
frisbees you know he's out there chasing
a frisbee that was you know that just
topped out at about 20,000 feet and that
thing might not land until Idaho but
that's how Eddie Bravo is he's out there
he's out there and it was interesting to
hear a man I mean it was interesting
just if you didn't get to catch the
interview it was just interesting to
hear a man who had had who'd taken on so
many things in his life everything he
got into not only was he able to get
involved and really delve into it music
sports chasin ladies but he made it into
a business along the way so he was able
to take his passions and make them into
enough of a business where he was able
to sustain himself while he chased
individual dreams and that's I mean
that's that's amazing I mean that's
amazing
to think that oh I like something so I'm
gonna make it you know I'm gonna make my
dream a financially sustainable reality
while I chase it and this dude was a
straight-up dream hopper Eddie Bravo is
a dream hopper if you see him on one
dream tonight you better you better
circle the clouds because he gonna be on
on
the dream tomorrow that man just goes
dream the dream he's out there just you
know he's out there just dreaming or you
know he's just out there just just
jumping from one dream to the next and
you know he'd done it he you know he
tried football he tried you know he
tried music he got into jiu-jitsu you
know now he's out there he's thinking
about outer space man his brain is left
earth and he's out there chasing he's
out there chasing what could be next
dude that get that [ __ ] a couple
months he'll build a shuttle and Eddie
Bravo will go looking for the truth and
is he a part-time astronaut I don't know
but I bet he's got it in his in his DNA
I bet it should if you look into his DNA
I bet the a stands for Armstrong and the
N stands for Neil I bet he's got that D
Neil Armstrong in him cause Eddie Bravo
you give him that chance boy he'll be
out there looking for the moon you give
that dude a couple pieces of siding and
some bubblegum and an old washer/dryer
bra that dude is I mean he's Latino to
the core he'll make the most out of
everything he don't miss a beat and he
about to turn that washa Tino he's about
to turn that washing machine and that
two pieces of siding you know that two
piece he's about to turn that into a
damn shuttle
you know viola El Bravo in LA galaxy
yeah but if you get a chance check out
that Eddie Bravo and it was amazing to
have him in studio and just to it was
just inspiring it was inspiring to see
somebody because what I do is I'll get
involved in something and then I'll you
know I won't i won't have the the
tenacity to also make it a business
while i am investigating it and he just
hopped it throughout his life from one
thing to the next i made small business
along the way made a band you know made
a juju start to learning jiu jitsu next
you know he's winning champion he's
beaten the greatest in other countries
other countries think about how many
other countries there are yeah so
many and he Bravo was beating people in
other countries so if you got to listen
to that cool if you don't know about it
he Brava that's the thing is he's a look
he's like one of them cans of um you
ever get one of those Kansas snakes in
the mail somebody sent you a can of
snakes fake snakes and you think oh it's
just a can
it's just Pringles it's just chips you
know about the sour cream and onion
myself down into a straight up couch
coma and then your spouse er your you
know your your friend of your love when
is going to come in you know a couple
hours later and found you just comatose
and some cushions but you open that can
it's not Pringles it's fake snakes
somebody since you faked snakes come and
they popping out and that's Eddie Bravo
man you ask him a question you take that
top off and you think it's gonna be
chips you're gonna have one he's gonna
have one it's gonna be that convo but
it's just snakes boy just snakes flying
out of that beautiful man
and look you know anybody that can tempt
the brain of Joe Rogan for years decades
even man I was an honor to have him in
studio and uh and it was fun
it was fun because you know he talks a
lot about outer space he thinks out he
thinks outer space is fictional you know
someone he looks up at the stars it's
like you and me just looking at a
painting you know he thinks somebody did
it and it's out there you know it's like
something that Microsoft made or
something and I don't I don't disrespect
it you know my original thought is to
think like ah you know maybe that's
crazy but is it crazy dude I showed up
here on a ball of dirt and water and
fell out I fell out of a uterus bro a
uterus something that's hard to spell
I fell out of that in Nuuanu a ball of
dirt and water floating in the middle of
nowhere could anything be crazier than
that doubt si doubt si doubt see ya
ma'am I come out thank you guys for
joining me here today man I'm happy to
be with you guys thank you guys for
checking out that e Bravo episode you
can also I was on this thing called JK
news
and you could see it on YouTube and look
I'll be straight up with you these
people in there are Asian and Latino and
by Latino I mean pretty much Mexican and
man I was nervous when I got in there
and I was nervous I guess you know I was
nervous because you know honestly I
thought that you know I thought guess
part of me you know you go in a place
and I thought that these people were
better than me or that they were
thinking that they were better than me
and and they weren't they weren't it was
just as we were fear in my head you know
so I you know I got into this weird it
was early it was kind of early in the
morning for me I had a late night of
doing shows and next thing you know I'm
there and and and uh and I'm you know I
got in there and it's like a half hour
till we start and they're eating Asian
food early in the morning and some
people could say oh you think you're
being racist I'm not being racist
I love Asians dude give me an Asian
right now give me an Asian dude I'll
[ __ ] put him in my shirt I'll hug him
I'll hold him I'll start a family bruh
I'll put a cinnamon on him and start a
family of cinnamon Asians never seen
never seen by anyone rare very rare them
CAS and and but I'm not not gonna talk
about him not gonna say the word Asian
because I that's restraint enough just
described somebody to you and be vague
no elsewhere please if you thinking like
that but dude I was in there and I felt
inferior a little bit and so I was kind
of scared and I was on my phone and like
you know looking up like man [ __ ] on my
phone like looking up like sports even
though it's 10:30 a.m. there's like no
sports going on someone ESPN app it's
like looking up cricket scores and like
uh you know soccer Liverpool is
Liverpool in every soccer game because
every time I look on it it's just that's
all it is
Liverpool Liverpool Liverpool so that's
kind of how that broke down and I'm
sitting there and and then we got
started and it was fun man it was like
you know I've never you know what I
realized I'd never hung out with Asian
people that much and these people were
they had Vietnamese they had Japanese
you know they had straight up [ __ ]
Dragon Ball Z was in that [ __ ]
it got hell Asian I didn't know what was
going on and man they were more their
show the the Japanese and Mexican hosts
hosts that were in there were more real
than any of the shows I've been on I
think a lot of like in that there's this
thing in like um with some of the white
hosts that I've been around the white
culture where we are afraid to speak our
minds and those people are fearless and
dude I I didn't I guess I thought I
would go and it would be less you know I
guess I thought that they would be more
fearful for some reason but it was
inspiring I got in there and they were
fearless
they shared what they really felt and
they and they weren't and you could tell
where they came from they weren't from a
bad place but they were just very real
and it was refreshing and some thankful
to them that stuff's called JK news and
we did about 15 clips and it's all out
there on youtube if you want to check it
out ah but thank you for joining me man
this past weekend you know tonight I'm
going to oh I got to tell you this
Mickey got them hitters trickling Mickey
got them air sacs and if you you know
follow me on Instagram you see that we
put a picture of him up and he got him
man and he got him and it just man look
I got so many messages and I'm not even
him you know I'm just that liaison I'm
that third long baby you know I'm out
here pump it from the side just cheering
him on just come on man cam and and and
it was just great man I mean the dude
just warms my heart because he's gonna
be alive as far as we know and here's
the crazy part though I haven't got to
talk to him yet because I don't know if
he could talk I don't know if he's got
words in his new lungs yet cuz you got
to relearn them hitters but these guys
he's got them healthy sex that dudes
running on two fricken who knows how
much air he's gonna have he'll probably
be [ __ ] whistling by you know about
Thursday he could be hailing cabs by
next week that mother he could be
calling a dog from far away
anything and here's the wildest part he
he got them he got them um he got them
straight up in her you know them in her
air titties he got him from somebody had
overdosed somebody overdosed you know
and that's just such a crazy circle like
somebody was so sick you know they were
sick and they couldn't get well and they
overdosed and God took him out of the
game and he took them hitters and put
him in the mitt and I'm thinking my
first thought is do well what if that
dude was smoking crack and now Mickey
got them straight-up crack bags in him
you know he got them straight-up them
them them rock rockets inside of his
chest what if he starts that dude might
walk out of the hospital feigning for
you know FINA for that baby
that chemical Boulder that crack cocaine
him he might be feigning for that and so
I'm a little bit worried about that what
if that dude was smoking dope all day
and you know he got the trick lung
Mickey's gonna come out with them not
with them narco sacks he's gonna come
out wanting a hunt and a great he gonna
come out sniffing for grams you know
like a rabbit it's like a he's gonna
come out sniffing programs like a rabbit
like a rabbit that was raised in aa in
Colombia like a Colombian Jackrabbit so
it's a little alarming but at the same
time you know that's the chance you take
you know instead of having hardly any
lungs at least he got lungs even at
those lungs you know if they are
addicted to cocaine or to crack cocaine
I'd rather have mickey out there on the
street out there
you know doing what he's got to do you
know selling a little bit of leg or
vending a little bit of ass cheek or
whatever he's got to do you know at
least he'll be alive and so I'm just
grateful man I'm I'm just grateful to
know him you know I don't have anything
to do with it I'm just you know what is
it saying that son in that and that
shine song that we listen to it says
shine your light on me tell you my story
or something like that but I'm just
sharing the story man and it's a
feel-good story for me and man I take
that inhale and I know that Mickey's
gonna be doing that same thing and now
we can relate to each other off that
world hit so that's exciting man what
else happened to me I'm still on that
Palio's boy I'm still on that Paleo diet
and I don't know who Palio's was but
that I'm sure he died of starvation
because I haven't eaten dude ah you know
I'm saying I'll look down so when
somebody's talking I can I'm trying to
look down their throat to see if they
got anything in them that's how hungry I
am boy you know I'll lick a little bit
of chocolate out of one of your molars
boy I'm [ __ ] hungry and most of you
just end up reading like the bat like
basically it's not even about diet it's
more about reading because I'll pick up
anything I'll read it
it'd be like oh I can't have what's in
here and then I'll put it down so Paleo
diet is mostly more about reading and
learning I guess brushing up on your
reading if you want to brush up on some
reading do Palio's because you read all
the labels you can't have anything so
that's where I've been at what else what
else is going on trying to think of what
I've been feeling man I was they have
the Mitzi shore celebration of life and
that's the woman that started the um
that's the woman that started the Comedy
Store so I'm going to her celebration of
life tonight so that'll be interesting
I'm curious to see what stars might be
there I'm gonna try to put something up
on patreon for everybody but I'm hoping
you know to see some guys maybe Howie
Mandel you know Eddie Murphy could come
out Jim Carrey cuca you just don't know
anybody that's ever been associated with
the place could pop through so that
should be kind of an eclectic evening
and an evening of joy and so I'm excited
to be about there and be about that and
what else is going on man you know it
was kind of a calm weekend I did a lot
of comedy sets mmm not much really
oh I had a crazy dream dude I had a
dream right I had a dream that I was in
this Airport and there was water in it
and not only did you have to get to your
flight but you had to like swim to the
door you know you had if you had to swim
to the door of your flight and so that
was uh that was pretty intense because
it's hard to get to your flight anyway
and then everybody's trying to swim and
catch their breath and some people are
just laying on floaties and [ __ ] and
you're like damn dude I got to get to my
gate and they got a [ __ ] out
there with a mai tai you know and he's
hitting a cigar and [ __ ] and you just
trying to you know I'm just breaststroke
in ac-12 you know I'm trying to catch
that I'm trying to catch that connection
so I have one of those you know watery
Airport dreams mmm and I said we got a
bunch of calls that came in you know and
uh and I you know we're gonna try to
sometimes you know if we have a guess
we'll connect em we'll connect you know
whatever previous or whatever previous
episode we have we'll connect you know
calls and responses into the next
episode those won't a lot of times
beyond the interview episodes but yeah
we got a lot of good stuff going on you
know we got a lot of good things
happening here and I'm grateful for you
guys being here with us and being a part
of things
let's get we're just getting to a couple
of calls you know I'll tell you two
right now and some of you guys know it
and some of you don't that I'm gonna be
at cluster fest in San Francisco June
2nd and 3rd I'm not doing much time
there that's not my choice that's
cluster fest they don't want to put the
dog in the fight man dude you know I
can't man
this industry bro June 9th Cherokee
Casino
that's West Siloam Springs Oklahoma I'll
be out there June 9th June 15th and 16th
they Yuk Yuk's in Calgary come out there
and get that Canadian get that exchange
rate on daddy get that bus back exchange
rate you know I'm saying off I can lick
your cousin bruh bring him out wash his
skin and bring him out or her out I'll
lick your cousin ma'am June 23rd I'm at
Imbler Brewing Company in Bakersfield
June 6th through 8th I'm at levity live
in Oxnard and July 20th through the 22nd
at Charlie good nights
in Raleigh North Carolina I'm trying to
get some Chicago dates trying to work it
out right now we also have some Stark
County Illinois dates some rural
Illinois out there we'll be out there in
Stark County outside of Peoria and
Kewanee for a fundraiser at a theater
and I'll tell you those dates soon ah
what's been Hawaii
dude Hawaii the earth is breaking and
they got that hot they got that hot
sauce coming out you'd imagine
cuz remember that game used to play when
your kid lava and like there was just
lava everywhere and you couldn't step on
the floor you to stand on a chair and
get a jump on the couch and get a jump
on the on the on the end table and then
you mom beat your ass remember that
remember that part it was like lava jump
on the couch you jump on the chair jump
on the end table mom beat ass that's but
that's real life in Hawaii and what's
crazy is you think with all these
surfers they'd have somebody that would
have one of those surfboards where they
could get out there on that sand and
surf that lava you know I'm saying
where's Tony Hawk now you know Tony Hawk
just had his 50th birthday party or you
know 45th birthday party or 30th or
something he's an adult he's tall so
he's been an adult probably longer than
a lot of people and he had where's he at
you know where's rob dyrdek rob dyrdek
always talking about here badass and
stuff like that you know he's - he
always talking about he that five footed
badass he's the white Nate Robinson but
where he's at with that skateboard you
know what I'm saying
I'm talking about your boy Elon Musk why
don't you lin rob dyrdek a skateboard
let him get out there and rock you know
rock that lava where's big who killed
big somebody will be out there big would
be out there on something on a pontoon
boat let's see it we're steve-o where's
a you know where steve-o dude where's
what's-his-name mom Johnny Johnny
Knoxville where's Johnny next Ville get
out
he's out there farting in gym class or
whatever and telling people and you know
throwing his nuts down um you know
throwing his nuts you know into a
Children's Academy or whatever why don't
you see what you could do get out there
hop on a refrigerator door and rock that
lava you know everybody wants to say
they're the best at this they're the
best at that but now they got a great
opportunity do a fundraiser
you know GoFundMe I bet you can raise
two mil to see [ __ ] do you'll serve
that lava see how far you go catch a
tidal wave who's a great surfer let me
look up right now great surfers
everywhere because I want to say America
because anything could happen let me see
some images right here [ __ ] - [ __ ]
great adult surfers let me look up that
adult surfers that you should know
that's better okay here we go
famous adults surf water all right okay
who else they say out there surfing I
don't know this goggle sucks dude
everything is just it all just leads to
Rihanna that's the thing about Google so
I didn't find anything but you don't
want to saying get out there who else is
a good surfer who's supposed to be out
there
x-games Oh Shawn white where you at
Shawn white huh
you got that fire you got that fire top
in that fire Raj well get a board baby
and hit that fire make it do that
triumvirate make it full circle ride
that lava daddy you got there winning
them easy gold medals get out there and
hit that volcano okay daddy
were you at now where are you at with
your talents
everybody's saying they talented but
nobody wants to nobody wants to get out
there and and uh you know nobody wants
to get out there and and ride on the on
the breast of Mother Nature nobody wants
to get out there and ride on the fire
backstrap of hades that lava flow that
Hawaiian lava flow that's going on right
now are you a next game or let's see it
you hopped up on Mountain Dew or
whatever you that Red Bull cement
jumping out of space land him back on
earth that's [ __ ] easy I want to see
somebody ride that lava who is it who do
you think should ride that lava get out
there Rosie O'Donnell put her loud ass
out there Kathy Griffin or Andy Dick the
same person put her out there
Chelsea Handler get out that boom boom
you know it all huh
get out there get out there and surf
that lava baby girl
let's see who's hot now [ __ ] pissing
me off man everybody's saying all this
[ __ ] and nobody's out there but anyhow
man you know Rhett you know Big Love to
Hawaii I know one man out there and he's
a good man and I've recently was in Maui
and I had a blast and I've been a kawaii
and it's just a beautiful place and I
don't know why they're doing that I
don't know why this is happening out
there and they got that magma they
called it magma you never know the magma
boy magma sounds like a crazy girl
doesn't oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] magma
oh is that magma Jackson dayum oh she
got her leg braces off girl
damn that's magma Jackson oh is is a oh
[ __ ] magma didn't bring over lunch she
gonna [ __ ] somebody up
magma sound like a crazy name sounds
almost Russian a little bit
who knows dude I don't know I don't even
know what's going on today I'm just in
that weird
I'm just in that weird space I guess
okay all right I'm trying to stay alive
let's do it let's get into some of these
calls some calls you know I always ask
who's listening to the show and let's
get a hit of who's listening right here
[Music]
dang Jesus sir hey Zeus up there in San
Jose and that sounds like a Latino name
that's probably a beautiful name and
that sounds like a lot of pressure bro
dude it sound like a lot of pressure you
know what I'm saying roll do you ever
notice like some Latino guys when they
talk they start getting looking just
higher and higher at the sky you know oh
I'm up here now um thank you for calling
Isis I appreciate it man uh that's sound
like a lot of pressure being named after
Jesus gosh do you got
that's like naming your kid Michael
Jordan like I met a dude named Michael
Jordan Network at the airport one time
I'm like damn bro like if you was you
know you know uh Sherman Jordan then
yeah work at the airport it's nice I got
a nice squat over there
you know you working for Virgin Atlantic
or you know uh or uh knighted
but damn [ __ ] Michael Jordan out here
going through two for two on these check
bags Shh just a lot of pressure man so
let's hear more hey Suze thanks for
calling and I am a cook a line cook I
guess you could say I work for a
corporate facility don't know if I'm
supposed to say the name but [ __ ] I'm
say it anyway uh I work for one of the
Apple cafes where they feed their
employees and Wow
hey suits that line cook and I'll be
honest dude working in a working as a
cook do you'll end up on drugs man so be
careful out there you know especially if
you're Jesus dude people gonna be
offering you dope cuz everybody want to
[ __ ] bust a rail with Jesus and I'm
not trying to sound sacrilege
that is the truth that's the crazy part
dude if somebody met Jesus and he was
trying to talk you know really kind of
keep him straight straight edge you know
if somebody gonna try to bust JC or rail
someone's gonna try to sneak him that
8bz somebody gonna you know someone
gonna drop a couple of straight rocks in
his pox you know somebody going to
[ __ ] you know just try to you know
somebody trying to somebody go and try
to get a couple grams up in his system
try to get up in this Philippines but
I'll try to fill his phillipians up with
some of that dust dust some of that dust
dust yeah man oh so I look and you're at
Apple what do you feed those people what
do they eat people at Apple I can't even
imagine huh
I bet it just seemed to me like they
would just come through like robots you
know like they just all have some
sunburn on their face from the screen
just screen burn you know some dudes
been on google for set on a search
engine for so long he just has it like
imprinted into his face on word hey Zeus
thanks for calling and thanks for
listening let's hear more it's a cool
dog I went to culinary school a couple
years ago and this is where I ended up
cuz the money is better than working at
a restaurant and the hours don't suck
ass this is what I am doing feeding a
bunch of programmers and bunch of what -
nerds basically yeah I said you got them
nerd eats you got them there bro you
should do a little thing we throw a
couple treats in there and watch a
couple of them dudes catch them watch
them get all fired up play three flies
in with a couple of bugles or some
Fritos you know watch them glasses get
all steamed up a couple of dudes nerd
and now a couple of dudes geeked up
carpal tunnel that's carpal tunnel
country because you know people get all
hopped up on them space bars and you
know and next thing you know they can't
move their arms you know and they got a
hug elbows first they can't really use
their hands so they can't even juggle
lettuce you know a lot of times they
won't juggle let us have three balls
just sitting next to them and they'll
just be standing there you know when
people that carpal tunnel is a dangerous
thing
you know I had this lady I used to work
at this insurance company and this lady
had it and she was kind of heavy enough
she had real real chunky forearms I mean
this lady probably had about 16 pound
forearms on each arm and the biceps were
smaller you don't see that you know
that's almost like a nocturnal creature
and she had that carpal tunnel and she
couldn't do she would get this milkshake
and she had to like almost lean back
like kind of lean back and land in her
chair and then laying the milkshake on
her shoulder and then catch that hit out
that shape you know catch that hit out
that sweet milk cup so because she
couldn't you know she had them heavy
army and dude this lady was you know she
had you know thirty-two pounds of
forearm and carpal tunnel that means her
fingers was all busted out
she had them riddick bowe knuckles you
know her fingers was all you know not
doing well and probably just moving back
to Philadelphia
you know she had them Bernard Hopkins as
his owner so you know you got to be
careful out there I mean you got to be
careful when you feed them those people
don't feed them something heavy you know
if these are programmers and they
running them keys all day you know when
they hit in them and dude programmers
bro they're naughty like we're regular
people we use asdf JKL sim we use the
regular space bars you know maybe hit
one in two once in a while maybe look up
and see where the other numbers are and
hit one of those but programmers they
use the outside buttons outside of the
middle stuff I don't even know what that
is that stuff one of those things is
just as like a like that what the [ __ ]
is that bro like a sideways straight
line that just kind of fell over it's
like a tree that [ __ ] fell over but
didn't fall all the way what is that if
they got all kind of [ __ ] over there
little shark faces they have everything
and that's where those guys operate in
that outside realm in that sphere
you know they out there and that are in
that um what do they call that that ah
what the [ __ ] is that work
I don't know in that you know in that
coral reef of computering so they're out
there but yeah my said be careful don't
give them something heavy don't keep
don't give him that two pound burger
you'll [ __ ] snap a dude's wrist you
know that dude's supposed to you know
he's supposed to program the next [ __ ]
you know Safari or lying or whatever
they got you know Guatemalan [ __ ] monkey
whatever the new iOS operating system is
gonna be you know that leopard or
whatever that cheetah that milf
they wouldn't milfy a good operating
system that thing always wants to [ __ ]
but anyhow onward thanks for calling we
keep doing things I will keep supporting
you the this past weekend family loves
you
thanks hey Zeus man I appreciate that
dude thank you for working hard man you
went in there you got your degree you
got that culinary and now you have there
working at Apple next thing you know
you're gonna hear something and in at
work when are you gonna hear somebody
drop a little bit of knowledge that
stock tip you know you're gonna hear
some somebody's gonna drop a ha you know
maybe a um a little USB Drive that has
the secrets of the universe on it and
you're gonna get that bit can be like
dang Pluto is back they found Pluto or
you know I'm saying or Chewbacca was
just a lesbian you're gonna find out
that rare [ __ ] that we don't know
because you're in there you're working
in the realm thanks for listening a Zeus
uh and thanks for calling onward let's
hear another let's hear another call
your own struggle about if you didn't
know if you could say I'm an argument
relationship for long yep that's true
mmm that's a big fear of mine and I
appreciate you calling let's hear more
Jeff a long time I think similarly to
other Dark Arts like II quit doing coke
which is very
you say you make the decision every day
you know but I'm not gonna not going to
drink or drug today
and I think a lot of people in
relationships don't do that with
concerns - cheating on their partner I
think if you leave it up to circumstance
that's going to happen when you meet
somebody you can kind of gauge where
that where that new friendship or
relationship is going to go you know
you're right when you if you leave it up
to circumstance that's true because
circumstance is controlled now this
didn't you know this in 20 years ago
when circumstance was circumstance
oh yes somebody might see you singing in
the lounge and you know they'll give you
a record deal bad at this st. then you
might bump into somebody and next that
might not be the case now circumstance
is controlled so you know it's like you
see you see in that you could you know
you click on an ad for shoes on Facebook
and next thing you know you walk outside
and there's three models walking through
your apartment complex and they all
wearing those [ __ ] sneakers you're
like damn this bleep [ __ ] is there
where it got on my brain hoofs they just
they they pick these hoofs right out of
my brain that's how it is there's no
circumstance anymore it's all being
advertised it's being sold to you
constantly and that's the dark arts and
if you don't think quoi C is one of them
dark arts come on man yeah man you know
they got a buddy of mine back in
Louisiana and he and that's what you
talked to him he says hey cam and but
that do this there's no circumstance oh
you think that that oh look I love I
love uh you know chocolate-covered pear
slices I love those daddy loves them and
they just popped up on the Facebook it's
a blessing that ain't no blessing I mean
it's a blessing that you like him I like
him I love pears most underrated [ __ ]
fruit out there people talking to apples
people talking
[ __ ] a pair a soft pair that thing will
jump in your mouth and [ __ ] sunbathe
on your tongue we ever had pear juice
were do pear juice is so good it runs
out the side of your [ __ ] face
advertised that's advertising to other
people come get this sausage sauce other
fruits don't do that they don't have it
like that a pear knows it's good it's
like I'm going in you and Audi you at
the same time
that's that uncontrollable flow if you
got a good hit a pear well you leave a
couple of slices of pear out there
outside you come outside in the morning
you find a couple beautiful babies out
there a couple you know a couple young
you know legally aged shorties out there
lurking trying to meet you you know
because they know you got them tasty
fruits Popeye but being Oh poppy got
them through to us who he got them pear
slices hey puppy we've been sleeping out
here all night you know
no doorman your necesito must bear my
spares boy pears in Spanish what is it
yo spare us yo
nosotros Vanessa see almost must badass
that's a thing boy
a couple slices of pear that's baby bait
you put that stuff out in the yard boy
you show up everything you love is in
the [ __ ] front yard everybody like a
pear and if you don't like a pear guess
what knock knock who's there nobody
because you don't have any friends
everybody likes pears so you know that
but what was I saying man what was I
talking about here let me get back in
there
sorry I'm all over the place oh the
staying monogamous right it's not the
same anymore you know you got it's all
being pushed to you it's all just the
advertising is too strong and if you
don't make that choice every day you're
right and you know I don't make it as
much as I should
you know I give in to the temptations
where I'm looking at this and next thing
you know I'm leaning over to that you
know how to about 13 years 13 days off
that masturbation you know if they were
then doing that self ski you know
playing with your own [ __ ] meaty
little high-rise and I had about 13 days
sober and then somebody sent me a link
to look at a massage chair dude next
thing you know boy I'm massaging my own
[ __ ] furniture shot bleh I'm about to
you know I'm about to jerk an end table
out of my wiener and it just that's how
it happens that fast because the massage
chair has sexy stuff on it so it's just
that bait is constantly there you got to
be on guard for your brain you know what
I'm saying you ever heard of a
Rottweiler you got up you got to be a
thot Weiler you got to keep them
thoughts I'm that thought Weiler baby
you know what I'm saying if you trying
to send a thought at me or I strike
first and I'll spray a couple hits a
thought be going into the air and I have
just a you know steer clear thoughts I'm
that dot Weiler because I'm trying to
stay savage I'm trying to stay on a
track that is where I'm headed you know
cuz they got these they got they got
this deviant cook you know these ladies
running around with deviant crotch and
then and whether it's through
pornography or and you know outside
sources whatever they trying to get you
to swerd this way Seward that way oh
what is that oh is that some you know
titty in the distance what is it they're
trying to get you you know what thatíll
does you know these ladies will leave
they'll leave a bra or they'll leave a
bra in your yard and you don't even
[ __ ] know him they'd be driving down
the lunar - straw bras out in yards
you know just brassiere and up you know
frontside that's the way it is man it's
dangerous out there for men so if you
don't get up every day and stand guard
because we're not strong enough I don't
think I'm not anyway I
have that that thing inside of me right
now that is you know I'm susceptible I'm
an addict
I'll fall victim to the elements it's
like if it's rain and I'll get wet if
it's raining on I'm gonna kind of dude
it's raining outside oh I can make it to
the car without getting wet what no you
can't it's impossible only way you can
make it to the car without getting wet
is if you were like 1/2 inch wide and
1/2 inch you know also wide the other
way and you were able to run through all
those raindrops like Marshall Faulk you
can't do that you know not in this I
think maybe if you're traveling at the
speed of sound or something you your
body like compresses and you could do
that maybe but that's crazy
and that's not real it's not even what
I'm talking about
but you can't I mean this is we're not I
don't for me I don't think we have
whatever we put it they put in our head
this is war this is mental warfare and
you got to have that thought while err
because that thought while err needs to
be striking down just biting yeah chiz
down oh here come on a BS that want
something yeah and here come on got a
guru batches at the end you got to have
that thought while err then have him be
on the attack cuz that they come in for
you and they don't want you they want
your things they want your vibe they
want your soul but not the good parts of
your soul they want the nougat you know
they want to take all a nougat and run
off with a nougat sack that's why you
see thoughts sometime running in the
distance with a second nougat but they
don't want that nut you know they don't
want that core they don't want that that
uh you know they don't want that nucleus
so you gotta be careful man
let's hear a little more oh if you don't
live a new friendship or relationship
go if you don't live it in the bud
you're leaving the door open let's hear
that part again because this is a good
part onward I wouldn't meet somebody you
can kind of gauge where that where that
new friendship or relationship is going
to go if you don't live it in the bud
you're leaving the door open and which
space you're probably going to end up
seeing in that person look that's what
they say you hang out in a barber shop
you're gonna get a haircut you're gonna
get a haircut
if you hang out in a barber shop you're
gonna get a haircut you know when you
meet somebody what's going on you know
when you leave the restaurant you tell
your wife you left your keys inside you
run back in and you you're flirting at
the hostess stand with some girl you
know what's going on you know you know
when you meet somebody when you leave
the relationship how it is you know what
can happen we know we know we can't line
and say oh it's chance it's this it's
that we know you know you know that's
the possibilities and the consequences
you know it so you have to be on guard I
think these days
monogamy that healthy that you know
unless you have an understanding unless
you you know you're discussing this with
your spouse I think I don't [ __ ] know
man I'm not even married bro I'm [ __ ]
scared of it so what do I know
let's hear more you heard him that's an
adult male right there saying when he
wakes up in the morning he lets his
thought while or loose and he knows that
that thought while our garden his
grounds gang ah yeah I'm sorry I don't
have a ton of talk about today guys you
know sometimes I don't know if I feel
like a responsibility to have a bunch of
stuff to talk about but I'm trying to
think
think I took some notes of some fun
stuff I wanted to talk about but but I
can't find nothing so maybe that's it
for now let's uh let's take another call
here we got something we did have some
great calls that came in here we go yeah
this is Jay I love the podcast man but I
gotta let you know I think when you
start getting into issues of race he's
got a little lost sometimes thank you
for calling Jay I appreciate it
and that's okay man how can I share if I
don't get lost let's hear more so
specifically I'm talking about your
podcast where you brought the Kanye
stuff in one breath you'll say people
should never forget their history
because you're not going to and then you
talk about you struggle to the poor
white man as someone from the south from
South to man up for Florida but at the
same time it sounds like you're trying
to deny black people their history just
like Kanye was just like he's trying to
rewrite history talking about slavery as
a choice I'm just like Ben Carson did
talking about slavery as immigration
it's not that he's not allowed to think
it's not alas not that he's not allowed
to think out loud
is that when people talk [ __ ] you're
allowed to call them out on it right
that's true I mean you're right I mean
but I feel I mean I feel like and I
appreciate you calling Jay thank you for
calling man and thanks for bringing this
up you know I feel like yeah you don't
want to forget your story you don't want
to forget your struggle but if at a
certain point if you know what's the
risk in and and reframing it what's the
risk and say you know we're not you know
if you always want to think yourself as
a slave thing and not trying to think of
yourself as an immigrant you know and I
don't know I mean you're never gonna not
take something out of somebody's heart
or somebody's brain but if you repackage
it or re you know if you rebrand it some
does it does it make anything easier I
don't know I don't know
you know I'm trying to put myself like
into a situation where it's like you
know like wow people always thought you
know would say that I was a redneck and
so what I started to think of myself as
is is rural because I thought that
redneck was I didn't like it I thought
it had a connotation that you know left
me feeling negative in some ways it left
me feeling limited people would try to
put me on a host shows where I was like
redneck something I say no I don't want
I don't want that job that's not for me
cuz that's not me you know and so I
didn't want to be those things and so I
tried to rebrand that for me as rural
you know I'm from a rural place you know
because more people are from those
places and and and I can relate on a
wider level then then just a redneck you
know and just there's nothing wrong with
it but that's not me
but that's not me so I try to reframe it
it's something for me that's more how it
feels more comfortable for me to say to
people you know that I grew up in a
rural area and maybe that's not maybe in
my comparison isn't good yeah it might
not be man it's you know there's how I'm
sure there's a lot of faults in it but I
definitely thought that Kanye's words
were taken out of context and that he's
just saying you know if we continue if
we continue to think of ourselves this
way is that the best mindset to have out
there that's what I took from it you
know I didn't think he was saying let's
forget that we were ever slaves I mean
she you can't ever forget that you know
but at a certain point a lot of people
are about moving forward what the [ __ ]
we gonna do I can't do anything as
somebody's a slave 40 years ago I can't
do anything of a slave was people were
slave a thousand years ago you know I
can't meet somebody from Egypt or
somebody from anywhere real everybody's
been enslaved I can't meet somebody my
leg sorry bucko I mean how long back do
we get does the buck go back you know I
don't know I'm not trying to take away
anybody's heritage take away anybody any
thoughts about it but let's hear more
than I want to hear more man I
appreciate : Jay
I think this this is kind of one of
those things that uh comedians lose me
with sometimes you tell a bad jokes you
get booed you say somehow land is stupid
[ __ ] you get called out on it yeah
yeah I just don't think I don't think
that it's [ __ ] I mean that's why and
I don't listen to the media dude I don't
let the media determine what I feel you
know I would go listen it I went and
watched Kanye's hold the whole video I
mean I thought it was a tough place to
really have that conversation I thought
the guy came back with him a real you
know with just some just kind of a you
know with a pretty standard conversation
right back at him like this mainstream
sort of vibe but I also thought that the
man personalized it the guy that was a
rebuttal and with him on TMZ and that
and that the guy you know I thought it
was it was a good conversationally
people were sharing what they thought so
but yeah you're right you know and
people do they have the right to call
him you know call [ __ ] on him I just
didn't like the way that it was
immediately that it was bad oh well
mediately this is bad what if it's just
his perspective well how about this
article
Kanye's perspective on this boom and
that's what's happening with Kanye can
you put himself in the public eye
probably to sell his new album and he
says some stupid [ __ ] and black people
white people conservatives liberals
young old the calling them out on it
they have every right to do I love you I
respect you but I do think you should
push yourself have on a black guest talk
to someone who doesn't agree with you
[ __ ] talk to me
kanya doesn't speak for all black people
and either think personally neither do i
so get some perspectives man because I
love you I'm gonna keep listening keep
supporting video thanks for that Jay man
and thanks for the you know being
understanding yeah you're right
you know you're right that we should
have some guests on you know we'll get
diverse and we'll get some more diverse
gesslin so we can talk about some stuff
and have some different perspectives but
at the same time I can't not have my own
perspective you know and I know you're
not saying too but you're saying we did
say get some perspective
and that is my perspective you know I
just think I think people are ready for
just new ways to think cuz I think some
of these old ways to think aren't
getting us anywhere
you know we've had the same racial
issues in America for so long I think
some of this [ __ ] is just like 'less you
know is there or is there even any way
to move past it unless there's some sort
of financial equality you know people
talk about white privilege all the time
and I feel that it's green privilege you
want to put it as green privilege man
that's what I feel it's green privilege
you know a lot of wealthy African
Americans become Republicans you know
it's green privilege and how do you make
things equal I don't know how you do it
you know I don't have an answer but I
don't think anybody's had a [ __ ]
answer I don't believe any of these
political parties have and we shouldn't
expect them to you know you'll know
people you'll know when you're out of
line you say something somebody
disagrees with it you know or something
you know where you'll have a
conversation about it but I you know I
appreciate it you know like you're right
I'm not buying I don't know about what
it's like but I you know it's just weird
to me that Kanye it's like that the
media media is like oh this guy's a a
bad guy you know they'll jump on it
doesn't matter it's like oh yeah this is
horrible way to think let him because a
lot of people don't feel like that a lot
of people think hey let's is it a
horrible way to think is it a way to
think you know but I appreciate you
calling for Jay and I appreciate you uh
you know being supportive if you
continue to or not man and you're right
we'll try to get some guests on I've
asked a couple of guys you know I've
asked a couple of guys and uh and I
haven't gotten any yet but we'll get
some and um and we'll bring this topic
up when they come in this would be a
good thing to have and hopefully I'll
even play this call again so we can
discuss it let's go to another call here
we go
so this past weekend I went up to
upstate New York for my sister's
graduation and it was it's kind of
uncomfortable because upstate New York
do that's necked at country and my buddy
one time we met some girls at a
stoplight and I was up there at some
college doing a college show and we met
some young ladies at a stoplight you
know a couple of stoplight beauties you
know a couple of yellow lights shot is
ya him yeah a couple of yield bunnies
because that yellow light you got a
yield on it yellow and it's that we both
yielded so we stopped at the same time
right after that and we're at the
stoplight we started chatting with a me
and a friend of mine so we next thing
you know we end up at this house party
we go inside my buddy got a beer and
somebody at the party got upset that he
got that he got a beer and they beat up
my friend and that's pretty much it man
that was upstate New York oh and then we
all went out to a bar that night and one
of my friends met this young lady and
they ended up making love that evening
and I actually went to domitor got
locked up they took him down to jail for
I was partying basically on school
premises and I wasn't supposed to be I
didn't know this house that we were
partying I was on this campus where I
performed a show at blah blah blah so
next thing you know next thing you know
I got out of jail at like 6:30 or
something and went back to the hotel
room where we were all staying at and
the girl that had made love to my buddy
also we ended up making love to me and
that's I think women just like that you
know they like a bad boy you know this
is jail they like that jailbird they
like that day like that jail bunny you
know they like that jail bunny and uh
and that's that's that man that's you
know I think and this lady had the
darkest bush on her on her body because
some girls got that body Bush they still
rocking that front Bush and this was
upstate New York and anything goes up
there you know you'll find you know
you'll have a woman who'll have a tattoo
on the back of her throat up there
you know Louisville woman just a huge
semi-automatic weapon tattooed across
her just right across our tits
I mean it's wild that's necked at
country you know that's tetanus shot
everybody up there stepping on rusty
nails and that's tetanus shot country
and this lady this lady she you know she
uh she ended up making love to me and
she had a real dark Bush man I'm like
she just dyed it with cold water you
know like she had just dyed it with the
own you know like the devil was making
ink pens and they went out of business
at the company and he had a bunch of
extra ink and she got a hold of some of
it because maybe her stepbrother broke
into the factory and and he got ahold of
somebody gave something to her for
Christmas cuz they didn't have much
money and then next you know she was
dying or Bush with the devil's ink so
that's something that happened up there
and upstate New York but let's hear more
Paul sorry I'm rambling I sit with my
parents and as my sister was graduating
her boyfriend actually came and sat next
to us and so my sister is 19 and her
boyfriend is 39 years old at 19 and 39
you know what can happen my mother was
uh 32 when I was born my father was 70
so there's 38 year difference so I could
meet a 9 month old right now you know
and not be interested in a creepy way
but you know be looking out for the
future and that would be the same you
know when that nine month old turned 32
that would be the same equivalent of my
mother and father but let's hear more
right here Paul so 20-year difference
going on for a while and needless to say
when I was pretty pissed you know the
dude was trying to make small talk with
us the whole time and just didn't go so
hard man so you know I just had to sit
there and I was just like come on then
he's trying to ask me about how I'm
doing and all this [ __ ] and it's just
like come on and I don't really know
what to do about that whole situation
yeah if anyone has any suggestions on
what what I should do here or what I can
do
really appreciate it thanks Paul I
appreciate it man
you know that's a good question man if
there's any listeners out there who
think what you know I have some
suggestions for Paul what he should do
his sister's 19 she's dating a 39 year
old you know they're sitting at a
sporting event in this man this adult
male is trying to chat him up trying to
get into his ears but you know with
thoughts and ideas and questions well
I'll say this man the guy could have
played [ __ ] you know Ajit up kind of
rolled and tried not to speak with you
you know the guy could have played that
the guy but he's trying to communicate
some I mean he probably feel like he has
to he probably felt really out of place
you know it's got to be super awkward
and what do you do I think in that point
man you [ __ ] yeah I think you got to
give that dude cold shoulder man if
there's some 39 year old do running off
my 19 year old sister okay man no sir
get out of there I'm I just couldn't
handle that yeah I say [ __ ] it man you
know I tell that honestly I'd tell that
do to hit the road but then that could
create issues between you and your
sister so but you could always tell your
sister what you think you got to do it
in a caring way though if you do it in a
mean way then she might just rebel and
continue to date him just based on the
old you know just based on that fuel to
your spitting that gasoline at her so
but that's it you know that's something
cuz you got that man out there he's
trying to get that naughty-naughty
you know he'd probably out there doing
wild stuff with your sister you know I'm
not trying to get you to think about all
that but at the same time he out there
probably 69 and then doing all of that
[ __ ] you know and then they probably
laying there and eating starbursts and
[ __ ] because you know young people
usually have candy around so that man
he's definitely you know he's hanging
out by the devil's doorbell dude so yeah
you know I think you cannot let him into
the house that's for damn sure
so I wouldn't be rude about it but I
would go to your sister and it's let her
know how you feel and then after that
you know you have two choices you could
tell the dude to [ __ ] get to hit the
road or you can just you know be
supportive of your sister and just be
nice to the guy when you can
because you care about your sister and
you want to care about what she cares
about but I think that that's out of
line now if it's in Hollywood then [ __ ]
that's okay in Hollywood you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you know you
could do whatever you want in Hollywood
so let's hear more here we go
what's up vzz boya-chan from Vegas and
I'm not saying it's right in Hollywood
but I'm saying Hollywood will tell you
shit's wrong but we'll do it let's hear
more I was up til vzg boyo Jeff from
Vegas I want to throw my hat in the ring
for best last worst past weekend Oh Chad
he got the best with last worse last
weekend so also you could each each
month any time you can hit the hotline
if you got a good weekend or a bad
weekend hit the hot line with it and
tell us your weekend good or bad and you
know trying to be around 60 seconds in
time on your message or whatever would
tell us what happened and if it's the
best one for the month and we'll send
you uh we'll see you loud look gift bag
low sack of hitters from this past
weekend onward let's hear more I'll tell
you what I woke up with my I [ __ ]
stuck shut and one eye by left eye oh I
stuck shut that sounds like uh that
sounds like a [ __ ] movie dude it
sound like a movie of like some [ __ ]
that happened in a glue factory let's
hear more what happened with that first
of all I had to call out of work because
I was well first I thought I was gonna
get some benadryl and just move some
allergies I sent a picture to my friend
this nice Filipino lady and she said no
man you got a bacterial infection oh you
got that Tyrael you got that Tyrael up
in your optics let's hear it and I was
like what conjunctivitis
she said no I was like [ __ ] that yeah
you got the conjunctivitis dude you got
that conjunctive Ida's boy and we had
actually I to do uh we had a kid named
junk dividers dau menthe when I was
growing up this mixed kid and he was um
beautiful kid and he had a [ __ ] bro
he had the fattest
neck I've ever seen on somebody junk
dividers Douaumont let's hear more I'm a
grown man you can't get that [ __ ] as a
[ __ ] adult and well well junk
dividers man I'll be straight up that's
from you know when you put a little bit
of downtown in you uptown that's when
you got your booty on your hand or
something or somebody's booty on your
hand and you put that booty up in your
eye so that's you know you don't have to
be a damn scientist niosh it works bruh
that's straight up
that's that hand-eye coordination but
also with some booty in there let's hear
more long story short I'm washing my
hands and I remembered that I kind of
just ladies pagina that night before oh
yeah dude that's a crazy member and
that's one thing I remember that I don't
forget like about drinking and stuff
that's one thing I don't miss is just
that surprise memory it'll be two days
late and you're like damn I [ __ ] a
knee you just forget about that you know
anything could happen you know when you
out there drinkin and on the dust let's
hear more and then rub my eyes oh oh
why bruh dude that's crazy why would you
touch somebody's vagina and then rub
your eye your eye dude your eye is
straight-up like a vagina for sight bruh
that's that [ __ ] site cooter and you
got two of a man and their team workers
and they provide visuals for you bruh
that's your vision ha's and you're out
there you touch in some adult lady you
said that mean anywhere from 30 to 70 on
the dance floor
so I'm guessing probably thirty to sixty
five and then you straight up taking
that up till you're and you hitting
yourself in the visuals with that
straight up ku sauce boy come home like
yeah man yeah man let's hear more [ __ ]
got that
I don't know that bacteria oh you got
that terrier bruh in your visual area
more that big V hopefully it's not that
big G yeah you got that junked of itis
man junk dividers Dowell Mont and if
anybody sees him man please tag him in
this and uh so that he'll get to listen
and get that shot out but she had good a
good luck out there and we'll put that
in for our contestant you can drop any
uh any thoughts you have on this episode
or any episode nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three yeah let's
hear more ask away dude I only have I'm
probably a black belt in it or at least
a frickin I could be a light brown belt
in it let's go actually I want to ask
you a question about not masturbating
the last time I try to not masturbate I
lasted about eight d and then I couldn't
get any work done whenever I saw
somebody drop something to pick it up my
mind went to that place and I cannot
walk can't eat without thinking about
things I was going to do in my mind that
was sexual oh do you might be a dang or
a peace day bruh you know not to get
real Spanish but you might be a dang
pair of addict because you can't think
about it look man you got if you're
thinking about it that much and you got
to take a vacation you need to go to the
North Pole you need to go to the North
Pole if it even exists you know you know
if Eddie Bravo is your travel agent you
you're not gonna be able to go
everywhere but you need to go to the
North Pole and get into it out there
because that's the thing you got to
relax out there and let that North
getting your nuts because you're too hot
you're too hot man somebody drop
something anybody what if it said that
you know somebody with carpal tunnel and
heavy front arms and they drop and [ __ ]
and next thing you know you have to try
to [ __ ] them
and they just you know somebody that's
just not strong come on right you better
than that you know you're better than
that you're better than that you can you
know you just you but you got to relax
man I would take a northern tour Sweden
Alaska North Pole you know watch cold
movies you know what is a cold movie the
air up there you know put a book in the
freezer read it you know do [ __ ] that's
gonna chill you out because if you're
out there trying to [ __ ] after eight
days you trying to [ __ ] strangers do
that's a crime that's a crime
what's your more oh I knew I had to take
care of business as soon as possible
it's just hard to do my job that's the
longest you've been able to go without
masturbating and did you have any
problems I went in about 30 days and my
thing is I just get triggered you know
kind of like you but I don't have that
thing like I I mean I had that thing
that I kind of want to [ __ ] you know but
that's just that general malaise you
know that's just that general ambience
that's in my chest that's in my neck
that's in my nuts but I don't see
somebody you know you know that's loot
you know somebody that's you know drop
something on the street and want to [ __ ]
them just because they you know are kind
of clumsy if anything if I don't want to
[ __ ] clumsy people because I want
somebody that's handling my dick with
care but but I went 30 days and it felt
good I started to feel alive my legs
felt straighter what else my you know I
was talking to family and friends more I
could hear better but we are a view we
talked about this in the beginning that
we are at war with with with pornography
and masturbation you want to know what's
killing men is pornography I'll say that
to the grave
nobody jerked off this much as us I mean
back in a day you was a grandparent at
45 you were a grandparent you were dead
at 47 48
you know you died beautiful you died a
beautiful person with nice hair and
clean nice skin now we live to a hundred
hundred and six people die P you can't
even tell if they living you got to get
up next to him and check you know and
touch them or put a thermometer in them
you can't even tell back in the day we
died early because we were grandparents
because you know you only you know you
got married you had a work you might
have died of yellow fever or something
you wasn't busting them out here like we
are did we but we'll bust them for no
reason there's no reason we're not
sexually a try
we're just [ __ ] looking at something
reacting busting that's some saying man
it's catered everything's catered for
you its consequence everything is
customized right there for you
everything it's coming to get you you
know there's no more just oh there's a
random thing that I know is coming to
get you and it wants all the seed out of
your nuts and it wants all the money out
of your wallet and it wants you to think
the way it wants to you to think it
doesn't want you to think outside of the
box it doesn't want you to alright thank
you for calling doe Derek I appreciate
it
let's hear another call here here we go
it's up to you I don't know if you tell
my voice no but I'm definitely broken
man right now man I'm sorry you having a
tough time and thanks for calling in you
know it's okay do we all you know you
having a tough time today I'll have a
tough time tomorrow so thank you for
taking the first shift let's hear more
watch out that you could on whatever you
were to say oh my biggest fear in life
is showing my pain
grateful for them mmm showing your
parents you're not grateful for them I
can I can empathize with that home word
yeah that's pretty much it I don't know
how to show my parents I'm grateful for
them without spending money that I don't
[ __ ] have I don't know how to show
them it tears me up inside because my
biggest fear is before they die you know
I didn't have an opportunity to show
them that would be successful okay so
your biggest fear is that you're not
being able to that you won't be able to
show your parents how much you care
about them that you're grateful for them
without spending money that you don't
have and your biggest fear is that
before they die you won't be successful
well depended on my own and you know to
where if they don't have to worry about
me and it just it kills me that it kills
me and dependent on your own so
obviously you know it sounds like around
not obviously but I'm gonna go I'm gonna
assume because you know this is just a
one way calling I'm sorry about that
I appreciate you leaving the voicemail
and thank you for calling and uh you
know and sharing one of your fears man
you you know your parents here's what I
feel like is our responsibility for our
parents is to be happy that's what they
want us to be they want us to be happy
and you know I've had days where I've
had some money and I've had days where
I've had no money and and next week I'll
have both of those types of days and
next month I'll have both of those types
of days and if I can I couldn't fathom
if my parent of my mother's affections
differed depending upon which which type
of vibe I was riding or which reality I
was living having money or not having
money it's always been the same you know
and because it your mother just want you
to be happy are you happy are you okay
how are you feeling how are you if not
how are your finance I mean you know I
guess if your parents can offer to help
then they might ask how your finances
are but here's what I'm gonna go out on
a limb here I'm gonna
imagine that you know it sounds like
you're still you know you're still
dependent upon your parents um and you
want them to know that you care you're
probably you know it sound like you're
you know making some wild choices are
not really sure where you are in your
path in life yet and uh and maybe
there's pressure from your parents or
you feel that they are pressuring you
into getting your pass trader or you
don't want to get your path straight
right now and you are and it makes you
feel good to to put you know to kind of
blame them a little you know yeah it
feels good to say oh my pet you know I'm
just worried my parents won't feel
grateful you know I'm worried that I'll
never make them happy and you probably
make them happy just by being alive you
know now if you are you telling yourself
man you know they're not happy with me
just because that gives you an edge
against them like that gives you an
argument with them which then lets you
justify whatever behaviors you're doing
that that are keeping you from getting
your [ __ ] together I've done that you
know I felt I've you know I've called
somebody out you know because it gave me
something to stand on even though they
weren't really doing [ __ ] and that was
all just to mask what that I wasn't
doing [ __ ] you know that I wasn't
pulling my into the bargain
but no matter which one of those it is
or isn't man you know I feel I feel for
you and I'm sorry you don't feel good
but you know what you can do no matter
what is going on you can always
apologize and you can always start to
take the next right action and that
right action can be small it can be big
you know if your booze and getting
[ __ ] up every night it might be hard
to keep those things in line you know
and you you can sometimes leave a trail
of terror in your wake when you're out
there partying or not taking care of
stuff but I bet your only responsibility
as far as I'm concerned to you is your
parent to your parents is to to be happy
is to be happy
if you move to [ __ ] Guam and teach
yoga if you do service work if you make
a million whatever if your parents
happiness depends upon you making money
than nothi that's on them
if that's the real truth then that's on
them dude that's not your it that's not
then that's their problem you know you
always go to like al-anon group or a
12-step program that could help you kind
of figure out some of those feelings and
figure out kind of if you're you know
where you stand and all that and if
you're blaming them too much or if
you're blaming yourself or what that can
kind of help but if you're just blaming
them man and just because it gives you a
leg to stand on you know they're not you
know they're not going to think you're
grateful well duis t-mobile things you
know esteem well people do esteem
actions and things can turn around
quickly things can always turn around
quickly and the biggest misconception
I've ever heard is that a leopard never
changes its spots
I don't believe that I believe that you
can but I hope you feel better brother
and good luck and you're not alone man
love you bro you know keep it together
do something good take it easy chill
free to even watch 101 Dalmatians you
seen that movie it's about a wild lady
but she got a lot of dogs and so it's
crazy because you know she's wild and
she's dark but you know them dogs got
all just good hearts in them and so it's
a real juxtaposition type of programming
oh let's hear one more call here here we
go my name is Nicole I'm 34 my boyfriend
is 40 and he's struggling really hard
with alcoholism and I know you struggled
and I thanks for calling Nicole I'm
sorry to hear about your boyfriend I
started to hear about that what's up I
tried everything nothing's working I
think your passiveness in your
non-judgmental way of going about things
maybe something I don't know
knew we could try we've been best
friends for 15 years and I finally gave
him the chair
and it's really yeah alcoholics will
ruin a lot of stuff you know and I hate
to say it there's nothing that you can
do you could go to Alcoholics Anonymous
you could go to al-anon which is
different than a a al-anon is a program
for people that have lived with or had
alcoholics affect them in their lives it
teaches you what happens to you when an
alcoholic is in your life because
alcohol looks a lot of times will affect
everyone around them and that also is
not the exact technical definition of
al-anon but that's my own definition but
um but I'll say this that's he's not
your responsibility
you're you're your responsibility and I
don't know how old you are or what's
going on but I think you got to take
responsibility for yourself you've been
friends for 15 years you know he it's
you know he's if he's an alcoholic he's
not going to be able to take care of
himself and he's not gonna be able to
take care of you
so I think you know I think you need to
keep a distance maybe I think you should
keep a distance you know sometimes you
know the good thing about being a friend
of an alcoholic is that you have a
chance to actually really affect them
and you'll know what's right or not but
you can't expect to if you're trying to
fall in love with an alcoholic or get
them to shape or in shape and you know
turn your life into a heart shape
I don't know if that's feasible you know
and I don't think that it's a safe idea
they say when you get into a you
shouldn't even get in a relationship for
the first year so you know I don't know
I'm sorry you're going through that
though but I think some of those al-anon
meetings because super help they're
everywhere and you can get into one of
those and really really you know you
could really hopefully find some people
that can help you learn and help you
feel better I wish that I knew more we
got to write in right here this came in
through the this past weekend hotline
and you can check that out at a theof on
comm and there's podcasts you just click
on the podcast and there's ways to
submit to the podcast here's what this
person said I'm hitting up
excuse me I'm hitting the hot line with
something from deep down and all the
feelers here's the deal I'm a 31 year
old secret at the time I was conceived
my gay mother was doing coke with my
birth father she wanted a kid he was
married with kids already but my mother
promised him that I'd be kept a secret
31 years later still a secret would you
seek these people out if you were me
would you let the cat out of the bag to
potentially meet your real brothers and
sisters look forward to hearing your
input my friend thanks for the laughs in
that beautiful head of gender-neutral
hair
Dustin thanks for checking in Dustin you
know you can see by a gay mother and a
father on cocaine boy I bet you probably
born in about a maybe eight weeks huh 31
years later you're still a secret so you
have very little family your mom's sob
you have five siblings aren't aware your
existence due to the secret on your
father's side what would I do
I don't know you know I don't know what
I would do man I I think I would try to
find out would you be reaching out for
them are you reaching out to you know to
have drama in your life are you reaching
out to spill the applecart
are you reaching out because you
actually want them to know you know what
you know I would try to get it what's
the real reason you're doing it I would
ask yourself the real reason I mean you
can always be patient you know you can
never ask them too soon or you can never
tell them too soon so you could always
wait and do it'll you know when you're
know for sure one of my problems is I
overreact and I'll do things really
quick that I should wait and take time
to do so but this is a good question if
people have some thoughts that can hit
him for they can hit in on this they can
hit in they can hit on this and drop
their comments or questions two nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three we're going to get to one more
right in also we're this this episode's
always brought to you by the ridge you
can go to Ridge wallet calm slash Theo
and ten percent off for from Ridge
wallet and it's a beautiful front carry
and I have one in my pocket right now it
took about five days to get used to and
I love it
one more time I'm going to tell you guys
that
about cannabis my westcoast buds is a
new podcast go check them out it's an
inside look at cannabis comedy coffee
and spirits and the host is Jody mio and
we'll put a link in below for that what
else oh we had one more text comment
that came in hi Theo my name is Cristina
I'm 24 and I'm from Long Island New York
shout out in New York
can't even get mugged in Manhattan over
there too many rich people you got to go
out to Queens they really get still get
[ __ ] up I think I just wanted to let
you know how much I appreciate and
admire you for creating a space for
yourself and others to just be real I
love your comedy you're also the only
man I know that can make a mullet sexy
and that's sweet of you to say and I
don't know if there's a mullet but I
know it's something wild and your accent
too I mean goddamn but moving on word
yesterday's episode of tpw really hit me
in the heart in the best way possible
you're called with Mickey was what a lot
of us needed here I was all up in my
field sometimes I get so caught up in
the mundane routine of everyday life
that I forget to look around me and see
how blessed I truly am so thank you so
much for for being you I just can't wait
for you to come to New York and I hope
to have a conversation with you one day
stay fly brah
Kristina man she sounds fine
you know Mickey's conversation did that
for me too you know and that's what all
this does you know because I'm a last
minute learner something is I have to
learn at the last minute and I have to
learn over and over again you know you
can remind me to be a good person right
now and I can do it for 20 minutes and
then my brain [ __ ] shifts gears or it
wants to shift out and so I have to be
constantly reminded so I appreciate you
guys you know constantly reminding me to
think about different things you know we
had some good stuff today hey soos the
line cook I'm thinking in my bum bout my
boy out there [ __ ] juggling waffles
and [ __ ] you know maybe got a couple
of hits of shrimp in his jaw and he's
grilling up grilled cheeses and [ __ ]
you know just slamming it down
you know these programmers just [ __ ]
stuffing it right up in there iTunes
holes just [ __ ] putting it right in
that dirty browser spot you know I'm
thinking of my mom
boy Derek who's eight days off that bus
bust you know he's laying off that
masturbation I'm thinking about Jay who
called in and he's making me think now
about you know my thoughts on Kanye and
you know do I as my racial drive some
racial perspective issues do i I mean I
know that I'd probably do so good so now
I'm gonna have to discuss with us you
know see a black friend or have a I see
a friend that's different than me later
has a different view than me that I'm
have to talk about it with them you know
we got Paul whose sisters Datanet you
know that 19 on that 39 look I shut it
down bruh yeah man
so this is what this is all about and I
appreciate you Christine for hitting us
up and on that right in what else I
think that's pretty much it I just want
to thank you guys for paying attention
and being here with this
I got a room we got this um you know we
have that special from Mitzi short
tonight at the Comedy Store I'm going to
do the Jim and Sam podcast you can check
me on there Jim Norton and what else man
I'm feeling kind of antsy and stuff but
I'm trying my best you know some of
these episodes are fast and some of them
are slow and and and I'm just learning
as I go you know it's uh well life's
crazy you know life's tough it just
keeps happening and it's so hard
sometimes to get a hold on it and before
this is one thing about me being in a a
before I got an Alcoholics Anonymous or
you know went to those meetings and
stuff and I don't know if I always be in
I don't know but before I got in I was
always trying to control every moment of
life and I'll just you know I was always
trying to control everything and it was
[ __ ] just exhausting and I never could
control anything you know and I thought
I was you know I thought the world just
just revolved around me and there are
moments where that still flares up so I
got to keep tabs you know and I got to
try and check myself here and there you
know because our egos can be dangerous
and the way that I find myself out of my
ego sometimes is by trying to engage
with other people help others find a way
to be supportive call friends make a
gratitude list did I wake up make 10
things that I'm gracious for that I'm
grateful for anything could be from the
air in your lungs to your working cup to
your working uh fingers phalanges
whatever it could be anything to your
friend and I'll put a reason why you
know I'm grateful for Allen because he
lent me his overalls and they kept me
warm so then in my brain it's like I
have what I'm grateful for and I have a
reason why and that always makes me feel
more connected and makes me think out of
myself but uh you know every day is a
struggle man and that's life
we're out here to struggle how you gonna
you know how are you gonna hold your
struggle that's why sometimes I see real
rich people I don't feel bad for them
because you don't have what I got they
don't have maybe which you have they
don't have that struggle
they never had any struggle maybe they
struggle for the things that we feel
filled with sometimes you know I think
it's all cyclical man somebody has the
money but they don't have any they don't
have any feelings
somebody has all the feelings but they
don't have the money somebody's got the
looks but they don't have any heart or
not any but it's all it's an equation
you might have a two one and two of the
other or five of one and five of the
other nobody's got all tins and I try
and remember that you know because that
helps to keep me out of out of jealousy
you know I try to remember that I'm a
work in progress I'll be a work in
progress when I lay down in that coffin
you know when I [ __ ] drop my jaw in
that mahogany I'll be is still a work in
progress but but I'm
grateful for you guys being here with me
today and just listening to me ramble
and stuff
we only got so many calls in today we'll
try to do more in the future I know you
know it was what it was and it is what
it is
and if it's on it's on but I'm just
grateful you guys are here with me today
I'm trying to get some exciting guests
trying to get a lady in trying to get
you know what Guatemalan you know trying
to get everybody so we're gonna try to
do everything is you know it's a work in
progress
but I appreciate you guys being here I
appreciate the support on patreon I'll
be putting something out for you guys
this week
and just everywhere you know just
everywhere got some neat stuff popping
you guys be good to yourselves you know
just because I mean you probably deserve
it you know that's what I'm thinking I
mean what do I do
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]